muy bien ahora vamos a dedicarnos a
hacer las cuentas que quedaron
pendientes en el vídeo anterior para
encontrar el valor de la velocidad v muy
bien entonces lo primero que vemos es
que aquí ve - - b es simplemente 2 b y
después aquí en el denominador tenemos 1
- menos b cuadrada sobre ese cuadrado
entonces esto simplemente lo podemos
convertir como como un signo más cierto
entonces para ir simplificando todavía
más vamos a multiplicar de ambos lados
por uno más de cuadrada sobre ese
cuadrado entonces multiplicamos aquí por
uno más b cuadrada sobre s cuadrada y
del otro lado también uno más de
cuadrada sobre c cuadrada entonces del
lado derecho se cancelan verdad se
cancelan y lo que obtenemos es del lado
bueno del lado izquierdo podemos usar la
propiedad distributiva verdad entonces
tendremos 0.8 c x 1
que simplemente es 0.8 c
0.8 por b cuadrada sobre se cuadrada
entonces en realidad una de las sedes se
cancelan y tendremos 0.8 de cuadrada
sobre c verdad y esto será igual a
simplemente 2 b entonces si observamos
esta expresión podríamos ver que
simplemente es una ecuación cuadrática
verdad entonces lo que podemos hacer
ahora vamos a continuar lo vamos a
continuar lo por este lado es
simplemente pasarlo todo del lado
izquierdo verdad e irlo acomodando por
digamos vamos a ordenarlo digamos por
las potencias de b muy bien entonces
aquí tendremos 0.8 vamos a hacerlo un
poquito más grande 0.8 de cuadrada sobre
c
keith sobre c y aquí multiplicamos
mejora si sobresee x de cuadrada verdad
luego tendremos
2b sería como pasar de este lado
restando verdad
0.8 ce y esto tiene que ser igual a 0
verdad y sólo para simplificar un poco
más vamos a multiplicar de ambos lados
por c verdad entonces qué es lo que
obtendremos tendremos 0.8 b cuadrada
menos 2 c por b más 0.8 por se cuadrada
y esto será igual a 0 por c que es 0 muy
bien entonces ahora si queda muy claro
que esta es una ecuación cuadrática
verdad entonces tendremos tres
coeficientes verdad el a tendremos el
coeficiente b y tendremos nuestro
coeficiente c y que son los que
utilizamos para encontrar las soluciones
de una ecuación cuadrática verdad
entonces
se va a calcular como menos ve que en
este caso será simplemente 12 verdad
menos menos 12 serían 12 más menos la
raíz de de cuadrada que en este caso
sería 4 se cuadrada verdad el cuadrado
de 12 sería 4 c cuadrada menos cuatro
veces a por c entonces sería 4 por 0.8
por 0.8 se cuadrada verdad
cuadrada vamos a dejarlo así bien y
luego todo esto hay que dividirlo entre
dos veces a pero es 0.8 entonces eso
será simplemente 1.6 muy bien ahora
vamos a ver si podemos simplificar un
poco más entonces b será igual a 12 más
menos y aquí podríamos factorizar 4 se
cuadrada verdad aquí tenemos 4 se
cuadrada aquí tenemos 4 y se cuadrada
así que factor izamos 4 se cuadrada y
esto multiplica a uno menos 0.8 por 0.8
es lo que nos resta verdad que es 0.64
verdad y todo esto va dividido entre 1.6
hasta aquí vamos bien y vamos a
simplificar todavía un poquito más
verdad de ser igual a 2 c + menos aquí
por ejemplo lo que podemos hacer es
sacar la raíz cuadrada de cuatro se
cuadrada verdad que sería 12 y
multiplicar por la raíz de 1 - 0.64 pero
eso es muy fácil de calcular es un 0.36
verdad y luego dividimos entre 1.6 muy
bien así que esto lo podemos ver
fácilmente aquí la raíz de 0.36 es 0.6
verdad 0.6 por 0.6 nos da 0.36 así que
vamos a bajar un poquito tendremos
entonces que b es igual a 2
más o menos 0.6 por 2 verdad entonces
eso nos da 1.2
dividido entre 1.6 muy bien entonces
entre en principio tendríamos dos
posibles soluciones verdad esto por
ejemplo podría ser 12 más 1.2 senos da
3.2 c dividido entre 1.6 pero éste lo
tenemos que eliminar porque nos da algo
más grande que la velocidad de la luz
verdad 3.2 se dividido entre 1.6 nos da
dos veces la velocidad de la luz y eso
digamos rompería con nuestro postulado
fundamental de la teoría de la
relatividad especial verdad entonces
sólo nos quedamos con el signo menos así
que tendremos 12 menos 1.2 se serían
simplemente 0.8
de verdad y esto va dividido entre 1.6 y
entonces observemos que en realidad 0.8
es justamente la mitad de 1.6 verdad así
que esto será 0.5 sé muy bien entonces
aquí ya tenemos la respuesta la
velocidad a la cual debería moverse
nuestra nave espacial c sería 0.5 c esto
tendría que ser 0.5 c
muy bien entonces en resumen empezamos
con un personaje a un personaje ve y el
personaje ve viajaba a una velocidad de
0.8 veces la velocidad de la luz y
queríamos encontrar un personaje cee que
viajara a cierta velocidad verdad que
ahora ya descubrimos que es la mitad de
la velocidad de la luz de tal suerte que
en el marco de referencia del personaje
se pues tanto a cómo ve se movieran con
velocidad
digamos 0.5 c
0.50 pero se tendrían que mover en
direcciones contrarias verdad entonces y
esto estuvo genial verdad pudimos de
hecho encontrar la velocidad que
buscábamos y en realidad lo que hicimos
fue hallar un marco de referencia que
estuviera digamos el que fuera
intermedio entre entre el marco de
referencia de ahí el marco de referencia
de ve lo que algunas personas no les
agrada digamos de los diagramas del
espacio-tiempo de minkowski es que
parece asimétrico incluso cuando ve por
ejemplo se mueve a ocho décimas partes
de la velocidad de la luz hacia la
derecha en el marco de referencia del
personaje a verdad entonces en el marco
de referencia debe el personaje se mueve
a la izquierda con velocidad de 0.8 c
pero ahora lo que pudimos hacer fue
hallar digamos vamos a llamarle un marco
de referencia que sea neutral verdad
donde ambos vayan a la misma velocidad
aunque vayan en direcciones contrarias
lo cual hará
la interpretación de los diagramas sean
mucho más simples y esto lo veremos en
otros vídeos pero pero creo que este
este problema fue bastante interesante
en sí mismo